the other big story tonight of today
rather of course is a republican
national convention president trump will
officially
accept his nomination for a second term
this evening against the backdrop of
this historic storm
an unprecedented pandemic and national
calls for racial justice in this country
vice president mike pence addressed all
three of those issues in his speech to
the convention last night
he praised the president's work over the
past four years and strongly criticized
democratic nominee joe biden paula reed
has
more on this story from the white house
in this country we mourn with those who
mourn we grieve with those who grieve
headlining the third night of the
convention vice president mike pence
framed the administration's handling of
the pandemic as
ahead of the curve before the first case
of the coronavirus spread within the
united states
the president took unprecedented action
and suspended
all travel from china i have the mask
right here but it was months before the
president acknowledged the severity of
the virus
and endorsed preventative measures like
wearing a mask
pence was the only speaker to mention
kenosha wisconsin
yet another city gripped by protests
over the shooting of a black man
jacob blake by police so let me be clear
the violence must stop whether in
minneapolis
portland or kenosha too many heroes have
died defending our freedom
to see americans strike each other down
we will have
law and order on the streets of this
country
but he made no mention of the shooting
that prompted the protest
or any of the black men and women who
have died at the hands of law
enforcement
and he said that a biden administration
would double down on policies that are
leading to the violence in american
cities
ignoring that it is under president
trump that the violence is occurring
the hard truth is
you won't be safe in joe biden's america
the night also saw a concerted effort to
reach out to female voters
who currently prefer joe biden according
to recent polls
i have a nine-month-old daughter she's a
beautiful
sweet little girl and i choose
to work for this president for her
a woman in a leadership role can still
seem novel
not so for president trump for decades
he has elevated women to senior
positions
in business and in government
later tonight president trump will take
the stage here on the south lawn of the
white house
to give his acceptance speech and make
that critical pitch for a second term
he's expected to speak in front of a
crowd of over a thousand people
the white house says all of them will be
tested for covid
gail paul the cdc is under fire for the
changes that they've made in testing
what are you hearing about these changes
and how did it come about
well gail in a stunning reversal the cdc
now says even if you've been exposed to
someone with the virus
that you don't need to get tested if
you're not showing symptoms
the cdc quietly posted this revision to
their guidance on their website but i've
been speaking with dr anthony fauci this
morning and he tells me that he was not
at an august 20th meeting where these
revisions were discussed
by the task force he was undergoing
surgery for a polyp on his vocal cord
now he tells me he's concerned that
these revisions could be interpreted as
lessening the importance of asymptomatic
spread
now president trump's re-election
chances have of course been harmed
by the pandemic he has repeatedly called
for less
testing the democrats have blasted this
revision saying that the president now
has the cdc
carrying out his political agenda though
a senior white house official insists
that these changes were made through all
the standard protocols
but paul from all that we've been told
about this uh
covet 19 do you think it sends mixed
messages
on an already very confusing situation
to test to not to test who gets tested
what test is effective absolutely gail
and from the start of this pandemic that
is what we have seen from this white
house the one consistent thing has been
mixed messages do as we say not as we do
quietly changing these key guidelines
when you clearly really don't have
consensus among your top officials it's
what we've seen since the beginning
but you can't ignore the science of this
of this covid19
wear your mask at the white house last
night most people in that crowd
were not wearing masks and they were not
social distancing at
vice president pence's address last
night
that's absolutely right no it is it's
very surprising again often and we've
asked the vice president this
uh publicly why is it so often they give
us guidance and then they don't follow
it everything from shaking hands
to wearing masks to social distancing
and the administration has really not
had any answers
all right i say again pay attention to
the science thank you paula reed
thank you very much we'll talk with you
a little bit later on